Speaker 1: Donald Trump is now openly begging
for money in an orange conspiracy rant and
a bunch of his loser followers are giving
him the money.
Why would you give a supposed billionaire
a little bit of cash because of his claim
that he's getting arrested?
Well, we'll get to that.
This is an unbelievable video.
Unbelievable video called Dismantle the Deep
State and Reclaim Our Democracy.
Will remind you what the deep state is.
But this is open conspiracy stuff from the
failed former president.
It is scary.
It is dystopian, and it is where we are in
2023.
Shockingly so.
Take a listen to this from Agenda 47.
Speaker 4: Here's my plan to dismantle the
deep state and reclaim our democracy from
Washington.
Corruption.
Speaker 1: Remember, he's a former president.
The idea now of, oh, I'm I'm an outsider.
Dude, you were the president of the United
States.
How were you an outsider of any kind.
Speaker 4: Once and for all.
And corruption, that is.
First, I will immediately reissue my 2020
executive order, restoring the president's
authority to remove rogue bureaucrats.
And I will wield that power very aggressively.
Speaker 1: Remember, what that is, is about
being able to fire government employees who
are outside the immediate political realm
like Secretary of State.
Right.
New president comes in to replace the secretary
of state.
But what Trump wants because he believes that
every random employee of the State Department
or at least or I'm sorry, of the federal government,
including the State Department and others,
is against him.
He wants to be able to come in and just say
fired tens of thousands of people.
Insanity in terms of the disjointed interruption
that it would be to the way so many government
departments function.
Speaker 4: Second, we will clean out all of
the corrupt actors in our national security
and intelligence apparatus.
Speaker 1: What he means by that is intelligence
agencies don't seem to agree with Trump's
unhinged lies, and so he wants to get them
out of there.
Speaker 4: And there are plenty of them.
The departments and agencies that have been
weaponized will be completely overhauled so
that faceless bureaucrats will never again
be able to target and persecute conservatives.
Speaker 1: Which they weren't doing.
Speaker 4: SHINS Or the left's political enemies,
which they're doing now at a level that nobody
can believe even possible.
Third, we will totally reform Pfizer courts,
which are so corrupt that the judges seemingly
do not care when they are lied to in warrant
applications.
This is a.
Speaker 1: Personal grievance of Trump.
This is grievance politics.
Trump doesn't like that there was enough evidence
against some of the people in his 2016 campaign
such that Pfizer warrants were signed by judges,
that he's like, just changed the process.
Speaker 4: So many judges have seen so many
applications that they know we're wrong, or
at least they must have known.
They do nothing about it.
They're lied to.
Forced to expose the hoaxes and abuses of
power that have been tearing our country apart.
We will establish a Truth and Reconciliation
Commission to declassify and publish all documents
on deep stage spying, censorship and corruption.
Speaker 1: Now, this this talking point we
looked at on a different day, which Trump
is now repeating.
Truly Orwellian.
Very often people say Orwellian, and it's
not Orwellian.
This is Orwellian.
Speaker 4: And there are plenty of them.
Fifth, we will launch a major crackdown on
government leakers who collude with the fake
news to deliberately weave false narratives
and to subvert our government and our democracy.
Speaker 1: And as I told you yesterday, extraordinarily
chilling in terms of what it means for journalism.
And then we get to the begging for money.
Speaker 4: 100,000 government positions could
be moved out and I mean immediately of Washington
to places filled with patriots who love America.
And they really do love America.
Ninth, I will work to ban federal bureaucrats
from taking jobs at the companies they deal
with and that they regulate.
They deal with these companies.
They regulate these companies and that they
want to take jobs from these companies.
It doesn't work that way.
Such a public display cannot go on and is
taking place all the time, like with Big Pharma.
Finally, I will push a constitutional amendment
to impose term limits on members of Congress.
This is how I will shatter the deep State
and restore a government that is controlled
by the people and for the people.
Speaker 1: Really crazy ten point plan.
Speaker 4: Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So this was sent out in a fundraising email,
and we're going to get to the fundraising
aspect in a moment.
Let's actually discuss the Deep State thing
just for a moment.
For those who aren't familiar with it, the
Deep State conspiracy theory is, again, one
of these elitist cabal type conspiracy theories.
The idea is government officials, elites,
rich people, transnational elites of different
kinds.
They're operating behind the scenes to manipulate
and control world events.
It often implies that these individuals are
doing so against the interests of the general
public and that they are responsible for many
of the world's problems.
Now, there's very little evidence to support
the existence of a deep state.
Speculation, conjecture, misinterpreting isolated
incidents or events.
What is true is that as a general concept,
rich people and corporations wield lots of
power in Western societies.
That's true.
They go way further into this puppeteer like
conspiracy, unified, coordinated group of
individuals.
And the truth, of course, is that there are
agendas and there are competing interests
in government, out of government in the US,
in Europe, in different parts of the world.
Oftentimes, deep state conspiracy overlaps
with globalist conspiracy.
One world government, New world order, and
all of it is dripping in anti-Semitism that
Trump is now regularly and openly claiming
he's going to fight.
The deep state, which has it in for him, is
really wacky when it comes to remembering
that this is a former president.
But here's the crazy part.
It's working to get people to give them money.
Trump's fans sent him a million and a half
dollars in three days after he falsely claimed
he'd get arrested Tuesday and that Soros and
the Deep State had it in for him.
Let's talk about
that next.